damien platts uh
people don't put that's uh ron is
romanian isn't it
yes
that's about seven or eight dollars uh
people don't put enough emphasis on the
importance of having a powerful network
it's true guys a power a useful
network i mean listen i know paul not
paul i know that uh andrew has his war
room i've got my own community um people
will will will flick boogers at these
things but they don't understand the
power of the network and what happens
unless you're inside it and you see the
use of it and you see the connections
that are made and and and the work
that's done beyond that i know um
because i've talked to andrew privately
a few times that
there's a lot of
useful stuff that happens in men's
communities especially high level men's
communities where you have top shelf men
i mean if you're doing some basic [ __ ]
um
you know doing like a book club or
you've got like a video game raid on
world of warcraft or some [ __ ] that's
pretty entry-level stuff the kind of
things that andrew and i talk about to
our guys in our community are very high
level and to be able to make a few phone
calls and say hey take this you know
take care of this that or the other
thing you want those people in your
inner circle you absolutely want them
their network is very very powerful
uh eric says tate your master strategist
go ahead
no but let's look at very recently gme
and gamestop look at how reddit took on
the hedge funds right people are going
to sit there and laugh at your network
or my network when a bunch of redditors
got together and bankrupted a hedge fund
right that's the power of networking
yeah that's absolutely the power of
networking that's all it's ever been and
and you know it's i love the idea of
being able to go to a group of people
who i can trust with with a problem
before i have to go to google or any
other crap and get it solved right
anyone who's gonna sit there the truth
is anyone's gonna sit there and and make
fun of networks they're just
self-conscious and they don't believe
they're going to be accepted into a
network because they're a self-conscious
individual
they usually you know you have value to
provide
the first thing you want to do is find
other high-value guys that's all you
want to do exactly they usually protest
because they can't afford the admission
or they think that there's dodgy things
it's it's it's usually just because they
don't fit in and it's like fine you know
if you don't fit then don't fit but come
back you know if you want to when you
when you're a good fit you know it's
it's not difficult
one more you said something really
important there you said about not
affording the price of admission and
that's another thing that i find very
interesting is that
when you speak to a person who is
of low quality right and when i say low
quality i don't even mean income because
i'm from a low income background i'm in
a low quality person they think in terms
of win lose because their whole life
they've either been scamming someone or
being scammed so when they look at a
network like yours or mine they sit
there and go well maybe it's a scam
maybe he's going to take my money and i
get nothing back what happens when you
meet with elite people is we all think
in terms of win-win
it's a different mentality right so the
win-win mentality is
me and him are going to work together
and we're both going to win there
doesn't have to be a loser amongst the
elites when elites were together it's
always win-win the pharma company and
the government are working together
right now it's win-win don't worry about
it nobody's losing right except the
people outside of the transaction and
this is what you'll have a lot of people
who flick boogers and networks are just
people who are low quality and think in
terms of win lose they go well if i pay
this fee he's won so i must lose that's
absolutely not the case if you pay to
join richard's network or my network or
any network or whatever it is
that's okay the person who
got you to join may win but you're gonna
win in exchange also because you're
around high value individuals this is
how the elites have stayed the elite
it's it's like a tornado it's an upward
spiral of endless winning win win win
win what about lifting all the ships
see here's the thing right i mean
like i've got a guy that i can think of
off the top of my head in my group that
i could
like i won't even call him i won't text
him we use a
app that is uh it's untraceable and the
messages you know disappear let's just
i'm not even saying what the app is but
you know if i need to make a problem go
away then i would message him i've got
my code name on it he's got his and then
you know you carry on through it but
you're not gonna have access to
these tools
because you don't have access to the
toolbox
and if you want access to the toolbox
you have to pay the admission like if
you're
you want to be the dumbest guy in a room
basically when it comes to a network you
don't want to be the smartest guy in the
room you want to be the new guy you want
to be you know the guy that shows up and
when you show up you don't want to show
up asking all the time either right give
me give me give me give me give me you
need to show up being useful like i'm
sure
you know these guys that you mention in
las vegas that you drop a call and you
fly them out and they and they show up
and they make their presence known
they're probably not senior members my
age you know
sort of thing they're probably younger
newer guys yeah
yep
exactly and this is the thing and you
nailed it as well in terms of asking a
lot of people don't understand the value
of networking because listen when i was
young and broke i would have done
anything to just be around important
people you have to know your place and
and also by providing value you learn a
lot
like it's amazing to me like people
watch movies and stuff you watch the old
gangster movies there's always a new guy
who joins and he earns their trust by
doing things and then he moves his way
up and that but then you'll get in in
this modern world a new guy will think
oh well just jump in and start asking
people for things that's not how it
works you have to provide value to give
value and you're going to learn a lot
lessons when you provide value like if
someone important enough comes along to
me with a problem i would love to help
them out because it will also help me
learn it'll help me you know like you
grow as an individual when you think
that way so yeah it's absolutely a
mindset that the elites have it's a
win-win mindset that that low-level
people just don't see that eric says
tate you're a master strategist sun tzu
the art of war personified that's a good
book make sure you read that read the 48
laws of power it's got some useful tools
in it as well you should connect with
marquette recently on f and f freshman
fed i'm guessing from the saint and the
sinner he's your brother from another
mother do you know who marquette is
i do not but i'll check him out check
him out i've i've never heard of him
either uh action movie clip says hey
richard tatum 20 years old living in
america with only 1500 in my bank
account working nine to five what's the
best way to start making more money and
how i get around high-level individual
okay you want to take this one
well you have online networks but i'll
tell you a really easy hack
because i've seen a lot of romanian kids
do this and i thought it was pretty
clever
have you ever been to so what happens in
in eastern europe if you go to a car
meet these kids turn up these 19 year
old kids with these amazing cameras and
they offer to take pictures of the cars
and they often often take pictures of
you and the cars and they build these
instagram pages of like car fan pages
and i was talking to one of the kids and
i was like hey why
why do you do this like you you you're a
car fan or whatever he goes no i just
want to meet important guys
and i thought that was really clever i
thought you're 18 he he took his instead
of going to uni he spent all his uni
money on a camera and now he's hanging
around all the millionaires taking
pictures and everyone's hanging out with
him talk to because he takes their
photos and he's getting like photography
jobs and video editing jobs and jobs on
the side i'm like you're making more
money than your parents i thought that
was pretty clever but that's a little
it's very smart though yeah that's a
great way to put it and i've often said
to guys you know if you can join a car
club a car community i mean obviously
you're not going to get in with the
hyper cars and the supercars but if
you've got a few bucks to run you know
we're up together and you can buy a 20
or 30 thousand dollar
decent you know performance car a bmw m
amg mercedes like something like that um
start going to those clubs there's going
to be people at those events with
supercars with doors that go up there's
going to be people that you might have
an opportunity to photograph you know
like andrew said that's a great way to
get into it i mean
the big mistake that most guys make and
i'll tell you this because i get it all
day long i'm sure you get this two
andrews can i pick your brain can i get
15 minutes your time hey can i ask you a
question
and i mean like you've got a entry-level
club that people can get into i think
it's called the hustlers university it's
like 50 bucks a month
correct yeah so i mean there's that the
price entry is relatively low or you
could just show up to places and make
yourself useful and instead of asking
can i pick your brain because what rich
people usually hear is this guy wants to
steal my time and pick my pocket okay
they don't they don't think to
themselves like you know okay i need to
help this guy because he's got nieces
nephew sons daughters he's got family
members he's got you know his his
friends kids that he tries to help out
so if you're a nobody to them and they
don't and they don't know you show up
being useful first helping them solve a
small problem offer them a photo shoot
with their car you know that day if
that's something that you can do you
know that's one thing you can do but
don't show up asking show up giving to
begin with if you know you want to start
with something like that
you